after two days of closed door meetings
West African defense Chiefs say they
have a plan for possible military
intervention against coup leaders in
Niger we've already agreed and
fine-tuned what will be required for the
intervention
the Strategic lift capacity
what the Strategic objective are
equipment needed
commitment of members says which was
very very very encouraging echoas
commissioner for peace and security said
the West African Bloc had the resources
equipment and political will to act
militarily and the door to find a
diplomatic solution to the crisis would
not be open for much longer all members
of ecowas
present here today
have all committed elements they have
committed their own equipment they have
committed their own resources to
undertake this mission
so I tell you we are ready to go anytime
the order is giving
the D-Day is also decided
diplomatic efforts by numerous
delegations including ecowas the African
Union Chad the UN and the U.S all bids
to find a peaceful solution to the
crisis have so far failed
echoas says it wants to put sanctions on
every member of the coup leaders
self-appointed so-called transitional
government in Nigeria
they still refuse to free detained
democratically elected president
Muhammad barzum and are putting him on
trial for treason a move which Echo us
and its International backers say is
groundless and escalatory and it is Keen
to dispel rumors that policy on Niger
was being dictated to by Foreign
governments like niger's former colonial
power France
is doing this in defense of its
principles those who are misinforming
the public that Equus is being
teleguided or being directed by this
power or that power they you know they
are missing their point completely with
any military intervention plan against
niger's co-leaders faces many political
and legal hurdles before it could ever
be implemented
these include approval by parliaments
and legislative bodies of participating
West African States
a number of which including Regional
Powerhouse Nigeria have already said no
to any potential military action yet
is commissioner for piece of security
was definitive in saying that this is
not a war against Niger he said that
it's expected possibly in the next 24
hours or so a committee of ecos
Representatives could well travel to the
Nigerian capital and the Amy for
discussions with the coup leaders this
is something that the coup leaders have
said in recent days that they are still
open to however
defense Chiefs here now say that these
kind of discussions cannot go on forever
and if necessary they are ready to go
Charles Stafford Al Jazeera a craft